all right let's see we're on page
471 we'll start with uh section six now
so let's do the first problem and i will
do it in magenta
problem number one
three plus
diamond
over 2
is equal to 7 and a half
and they say what number when used in
the place of diamond above makes the
statement true well they're just making
the diamond the variable right so we
could just say you know 3 plus x
over 2 instead of an x of a diamond
because that's where we're used to is
equal to and i like to uh
well we could write this as a decimal if
we want 7 and a half
seven and a half
multiply both sides by two
times two
so you get three plus x is equal to
fifteen
x is equal to twelve so that's choice d
or we could say diamond is equal to x is
equal to 12.
okay problem number two
when they got they have this thing drawn
let me draw what they drew
i'm doing a different color
they have like a transversal here and
then they have one line that goes like
this
and then they have another line that
goes something like this
and then let's see they wrote a bunch of
stuff they wrote this is
angle 1 2
3 4
then
7 8 and these are lines l and lines
m
and they say the figure above l is
parallel to m so l is parallel to m
all right parallel lines
if l is problem the sum of the measures
of angle 2 and 4 so the sum of 2 and 4
must equal the sum of the measures of
which of the following
pairs of angles
so the sum of 2 and 4
right the sum of 2 and 4. and actually
we know another thing we know that 2 and
four are equal to each other right
because they're opposite angles
but anyway what what angles would be the
same as two plus four well we can just
do you know what we learned in geometry
class about corresponding angles we know
that this angle
is the same thing as this angle
and we actually know that that angle is
also the same thing as this angle right
because they're opposite and that first
one we know that they're because they're
corresponding and somewhere it's that
angle same as this one so 2 plus 4
should be the same thing as 6 plus 8 and
all we used is corresponding angles to
say well 4 is going to be the same as 8
2 is the same as 6 and we also know that
6 and 8 are the same and 2 and 4 are the
same
so it's choice d
problem number three
invert all right there's something
okay
let me draw this table because it looks
like we'll have to use it
so i have it's like a box here and then
let me draw some lines
so it's
all right
almost there
and then they say
men
women
total
employed
unemployed
total
they wrote in the numbers 27
000 those are zeros forty eight thousand
twenty one thousand five hundred
and fifty thousand
five hundred
in the table above describing the
preston city workforce or the table is
partially filled in based on the
information in the table how many women
in the preston city workforce are
unemployed so we want to figure out
women that are unemployed so we want to
figure out
we need to figure out this box
right
so how do we do that well first we can
figure out the women that are employed
because there's 48
000 workers 27 000 are men
so we just subtract 27 000 from 48 so
there's going to be 21 000
women
right and then if there's 21 000 women
right i just subtracted and
and uh well no sorry there's 21 000
employed women because we're in the
employed column and they're 21 500 total
women well then we just subtract again
21 500 minus 21 000
there must be 500
unemployed women in preston city and
that's choice a
okay problem number four and i will
switch from this
kind of nauseating
color i think
see problem number four
a group of students washed cars to raise
money
the net amount
a
so the a
in dollars raised by washing k cars is
given by the function oh well they tell
us a of
k so this is how much you've
made after washing k cars
is 4k
minus 30.
if the group washed 15 cars
what is the net amount they raised
well this seems unbelievably easy
because they tell you that k
is
15.
so a
of 15
is equal to 4 times 15
minus 30.
4 times 15 is 60 minus 30. that just
equals 30. they raised 30 30 that's
choice e
and and that one if i when if i was
taking sat i would have paused just to
make sure i didn't miss something and
i'm actually pausing now to make sure i
didn't miss a trick but that's i think
that's it that's kind of one of those
freebie quick questions
okay problem number five
and i'll switch colors for variety
if x r is equal to v
x
r is equal to v
and v is equal to k r
v is equal to k r
and we also know that rv does not equal
zero which also tells us that neither of
these numbers can equal zero
which of the following is equal to k and
all of the choices are have just x's and
some numbers
so we want to write k in terms of
in terms of x so x r is equal to v and v
is equal to k r so x r is equal to v we
also know v is equal to k r
right so we know that
x r is equal to
k r
and since we know that
r does not equal
right we can divide both sides of this
equation by r and they cancel out and we
get x is equal to k or k is equal to x
so that is choice
d
ah they're giving us a lot of quick
problems but i guess good i can fit a
lot into into one video
okay problem number six
the eggs in a certain basket are either
white or brown
if the ratio of white eggs to brown eggs
is so white
i should probably do it in those colors
but i'm not to confuse you the ratio of
white to brown is equal to
two
over three
each of the following could be the
number of eggs in the basket
except
so this is this is a tricky one so if i
the ratio of white to brown is two to
three right so let's say you know white
if we multi white to brown is equal to
two over three or another way we could
say it is
white is equal to
two thirds times
the brown eggs right and so the total
the total eggs in the basket are going
to be white
plus brown
the total eggs are going to be white
and and so we could write you know this
w we could write it you know it's
two-thirds
of the number of brown eggs is the white
eggs that's what we figured out here
plus the brown eggs
so the total number of baskets is a c
what's two thirds plus you know one is
the same thing as three thirds right
the total number of baskets is five
thirds times the number of brown eggs
so what this tells us and we know we
can't have a fractional number of eggs
so we know that this has to be
a whole number
so if this is a whole number we just
feel well what numbers can we get
using whole numbers that would
you know if we said
five thirds be this is the first choice
is equal to ten
could that be a choice let's see b
b would have to be three fifths
times ten
which would be this cancels out well
that works
right because then b would be 6.
so that could work
if b is well i think we already we
already know right b
the total number of baskets has to be
divisible by five right because b is
equal to the total number
times three over five i just use this
equation five thirds b is equal to total
multiply both sides times reciprocal you
get this and the only choice that's not
divisible by 5 is choice b
hope i didn't rush it but i had to
finish under the wire i'll see you soon